[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'étais tout gamin j'aimais
beaucoup l'histoire du petit prince
j'avais le bouquin avec les images je me
souviens surtout d'un disque vinyle un
vieux qui tournait à la hauteur de mes
yeux c'était un 78 tours alors il
tournait vite aussi vite que la planète
du petit prince qui était d'ailleurs
dessiné au centre de ce disque avec des
étoiles qui filait qui brille est plein
de promesses fait de ta vie un rêve et
d'un rêve une réalité
cette phrase on la connaît tous sous une
forme ou sous une autre on l'a vu revu
elle circule sur les réseaux sociaux
oui mais cette phrase elle et de
l'auteur du petit prince saint-exupéry
et ce rêve saint-exupéry l'a vécue dans
le ciel comme ces fameux pionniers ces
héros qui ont osé vivre le rêve d'icare
volée mais ça c'était il ya bien
longtemps
plus de cent ans pour ses premiers
planner est aujourd'hui sur notre
planète qui ne ressemble guère à celle
du petit prince où tout est formaté
aseptisé où le risque n'a plus vraiment
sa place ou souvent quand on vole ça
ressemble plus à prendre le bus est
encore aux heures de pointe
comment peut-on retrouver la pureté
l'authenticité de ce rêve d'icare
il est environ 30 ans j'ai vu pour la
première fois dans les montagnes des
alpes
ces parachutes de pente c'était des
voiles colorées à l'image de leurs
pilotes souvent habillés en flux aux
années 80 oblige c'était d'abord des
parachutistes qui voulaient se libérer
de la montée en avion ou encore des
alpinistes qui se voulait chercher à
redescendre des sommets autrement qu'à
pied des héros des courageux les
inconscients diront certains
ils modifiaient des parachutes avec leur
machine à coudre pour les faire avancer
pour les faire voler un parachute ça ne
fait que descendre en les modifiant pour
les faire aussi avancé planer c'était
gagné
on pouvait descendre des montagnes en
volant du tissu des ficelles un petit
harnais des escalades
le tout dans un sac à dos c'était parti
bon à cette époque les performances de
planer n'était vraiment pas terrible
à peine mieux que ses feuilles de papier
d'ailleurs le parapente est née en même
temps que son premier surnom qui lui ne
faisait pas vraiment rêver l'europe la
pente et l' aventure se termine est très
souvent dans les arbres voire bien pire
mais peu importe est pour moi le rêve a
pris forme il est devenu accessible
la magie du vol libre à opérer le
parapente est entré dans ma vie depuis
ses années 80 le parapente et les
connaissances qui vont avec ont bien
évolué nos petites elles sont devenues
de véritables planeurs des talents se
sont multipliées avec des joies et des
peines les limites ont été repoussés par
miracle cependant la gravité est
toujours là un parapente ne fait que
descendre et pourtant eux ils ont
décollé d'une colline de quelques
centaines de mètres et là ils sont
perchés à plus de 3000 mètres comment
est ce possible
d'où vient l'énergie c'est le soleil et
le vent le soleil chauffe le sol et le
ler à son contact se réchauffe à son
tour et finit par s'élever comme une
bulle en souvent le parapente comme dans
un ascenseur c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on
appelle les ascendances et ça marche
aussi avec le vent le vent qui lui
remonte en relief une montagne et
soulève le parapente avec lui avec cette
seule énergie les records se sont
continuellement amélioré à travers le
monde
d'abord de simple vol de pente
ensuite des traversées de vallée enfin
des régions entières
aujourd'hui on peut voler plus de 500
kilomètres en un seul vol
de rester en l'air douze heures de temps
sans toucher le sol de fabuleuses balade
aérienne
le tout avec un sac à dos et en un seul
jour
après toutes ces années ma fascination
pour le vol de distance en parapente est
toujours intacte la perspective d'une
belle journée de vol me donne toujours
autant d'émotion alors à ce stade je
crains que vous l'ayez maintenant
compris je pourrais vous parler de ma
drogue jusqu'à demain matin
juste une petite histoire il ya quelques
mois je faisais du stop au bord de la
route c'est souvent le cas au retour des
vols de distances
une automobiliste s'arrête je monte
bonjour madame merci beaucoup
forcément je m'explique ce que je fais
là avec mon parapente avec mon gros sac
sur le dos elle m'écoute
au bout d'un moment elles me demandent
vous ne vous ennuyez palau elle allait
chercher ses enfants à l'école et j'ai
bien compris que mon histoire de
parapente
elle a trouvé futile et inutile
dangereuse moi j'étais encore perchée
sur mon petit nuage et j'ai eu du mal à
lui expliqué mais ça va faire réfléchir
et aujourd'hui je crois en savoir un peu
plus j'ai réalisé que le déroulement de
ces vols de distances présentait
beaucoup d'analogies avec la vie que
chaque vol était une métaphore étonnante
avec le résumé de toute une vie une
sorte de concentré temporel truffé de
correspondance regardons ça le décollage
c'est la naissance quand nos pieds
quitte le sol on laisse la pesanteur
derrière on sort de la boîte en deux
dimensions et on prend une première
vraie respiration
d'ailleurs on peut même pousser un petit
cri comme le nourrisson qui lui découvre
son nouvel environnement à l'extérieur
de sa mère le parapentiste lui rentre
dans la troisième dimension en se
détachant de la terre-mère un moment
fort souvent le moment favori des
parapentistes tout est possible des
rêves les plus fous sont permis
jusqu'où notre destinée du jour nous
amènera tél le ciel est notre terrain de
jeu alors il n'y a pas vraiment de
limites
les débuts d'un vol de distance c'est
l'enfance la jeunesse
on est à l'affût de toutes les
sensations
il faut trouver cette fameuse potion
antigravité pour monter pour grandir les
ascendants sont notre élixir de vie
elles sont notre véritable nourriture
alors on capte tous ceux qui composent
trouvé pour s'élever pour grandir pour
faire comme les grands et de ne pas
finir en bas de la pente et bien sûr les
erreurs de jeunesse sont possibles on
peut trébucher et le risque de voir
atterrir trop tôt et bien présent
c'est donc à ce moment là que les rêves
doivent devenir réalité
il faut concrétiser et le rêve à ce
moment là c'est monté ça y est on a
trouvé la première ascendance on est
perché on est au est beau le monde est à
nos pieds tous nous paraît soudain plus
accessible l'altitude nous donne une
nouvelle attitude comme un ado enfin un
ado en forme on a doc opératif vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
on est optimiste et joyeux on est prêt à
couper le cordon
impatient de quitter le nid c'est
l'heure du départ
c'est la croissance validé c'est
l'émancipation du jeune adulte
mais bien vite c'est aussi l'heure des
premières grandes décisions
on veut l'autonomie il faut l'assumer
faut-il continuer de monter en restant
dans sa bulle pour plus de sécurité
ou alors choisir une direction tracer sa
route
les choix peuvent être lourds de
conséquences atterri au loin du nid
n'est pas toujours facile partir c'est
prendre un risque reste et c'est tomber
dans la routine dans la dépendance
syndrome de tanguy ou celui de
l'autodidacte
et puis un jour c'est décidé on quitte
le giron familial on gère son
indépendance au mieux possible on
découvre de nouveaux relief de nouvelles
options de nouvelles sensations
les hauts et les bas
les vicissitudes de la vie parfois
imperceptibles parfois sous forme de
bonne claque
ils peuvent être fatales mais ils font
partie du voyage
quand on est au creux de la vague
peut-être une mauvaise décision un
mauvais positionnement ou une influence
un peu douteuse et c'est la crise
l'altitude fond comme neige au soleil
tous les rêves s'envolent et c'est le
mode survie qui s'installe surtout ne
pas céder à la dépression qui guette
c'est la famine alors toutes les miettes
sont bonnes à prendre
il faut sortir de cette situation alors
incantations prière jurons chacun son
style ce graphique c'est un vol que j'ai
fait au brésil environ neuf heures de
temps on voit toutes les dents de scie
qui représente des variations d'altitude
parfois quelques mètres parfois
plusieurs kilomètres derrière chaque rue
chaque bosse il y a une histoire une
joie une misère je me souviens de ses
points bas pendant ce vol
j'étais en perdition à 50 mètres au
dessus du sol poussé par un vent chaud
et poussiéreux j'ai glissé au dessus
d'un petit village il y avait une école
c'était la fin des classes les enfants
étaient dans la cour ils ont vite fait
de me repérer ils sont mis à crier mon
suivi en courant persuadé que j'allais
atterrir et moi j'étais là en train de
me battre de gesticuler en restant dans
ma petite bulle qui ne voulait pas se
déclencher et j'étais suffisamment bas
pour leur dire que non je ne veux pas
atterrir c'est là où je veux aller et ça
a duré trois ou quatre kilomètres
il y avait encore sous - un groupe d'une
trentaine de gamins
les plus sportifs suppose et ceux qui ne
voulaient pas lâcher la faire et là tout
d'un coup il ya une bulle d'air chaud
qui s'est enfin déclencher et qui m'a
éjecté vers le ciel et je revois encore
tous ses enfants
immobile cette fois silencieux qui m'ont
regardé montée en tournoyant
il était sûr que c'en était fini pour
moi moi j'ai recommencé à respirer
c'était un nouveau départ souvent c'est
beaucoup plus zen
rassurez vous une certaine sérénité peut
s'installer les enchaînements deviennent
prévisible la lumière est belle on
récolte le fruit de son expérience
c'est la maturité qui vient avec
l'expérience
c'est aussi la sagesse de la vieillesse
en tout cas bon on aime le croire
parfois on a quelques heures au compteur
et en prenant de l'altitude on s'est
mises en sécurité dans ses mouvements
les ascendants sont organisés sont
généreuses
c'est un festin de parapentistes tout
devient un peu plus facile c'est le
temps aussi de la réflexion de la
gratitude de la contemplation de la
méditation sur le monde ce rapport à la
vraie vie
l'autre celle à laquelle on s'est
soustraite bref on philosophe
ça peut être aussi l'heure du bilan trop
vite
arrive l'heure où la fin du vol doit
être envisagée la douceur du début du
début d'une soirée annonce déjà
l'arrivée du crépuscule
la fin est inéluctable et elle se
rapproche alors on fait de son mieux
pour la préparer afin de ne pas la subir
on vérifie sa liste afin de ne rien
oublier
la boucle est bouclée laventure se finit
on atterrit alors si je vole c'est pour
tout ça est également plein d'autres
choses je vole parce que chaque voile
est un concentré de vie d'une grande
intensité
on prend des risques on joue sa vie
et surtout en jour et oui on peut
recommencer vol après vol a encore et
encore alors on joue et on rejoue mais
on peut aussi s'ennuyer si on refait la
même chose on peut tomber dans la
routine
alors on essaie de s'améliorer à chaque
moment la naissance la croissance la
maturité et la sagesse même le
crépuscule je vous ai dit aussi qu'on
pouvait voler à deux jouer à deux en
biplace et s'y attellent moment je
faisais autrement et si je sortais de
mes habitudes pour mieux jouer alors
voulons et joue en tant que le soleil
brillera merci
[Applaudissements]